[Music]
so here's something a chain-smoking
robot looks like we've got a regular
Marlboro Man over here now to be clear
human smoking isn't as cool as if
tobacco companies would have you believe
but a smoking robot is totally cool
because it's helping scientists at the
visa Institute at Harvard better
understand COPD or chronic obstructive
pulmonary disease
get me the intense coughing and
shortness of breath and infections
common among smokers this thing is
pretty darn brilliant
it begins with what's known as a
lung-on-a-chip it ends up looking a bit
like a human airway and comes complete
with human lung cells because it has
these cells it also produces mucus and
has hair like structures called cilia
that move the mucus around the robot
itself is pretty much a Gatling gun of
cigarettes an automated lighter from a
car fires up each smoke the researchers
can even program the robot to huff at
different intervals in intensity and by
loading up the lung chips with either
the cells from a patient with lung
disease or a nonsmoker the scientists
can see how smoke effects each
differently the findings could lead to
new treatments for sufferers of COPD and
do away with the old method sticky rats
in a box of smoke so huff away little
one and do mine the ash